euh Titanic ben artiste oui euh adieu
les cons ouais ça aurait été dommage que
tu Buges sur lui oui le Parin très bien
ça c'est facile Amélie Poulin très bien
Gladiator les premers sont faciles très
bien on enchaîne euh la haine très bien
jeis ah merde ça c'est hyper connu c'est
oui c'est le Seigneur de des anneaux des
anneau ça c'est Benjamin voisin dans les
illusions perdues oui exactement ça
c'est je l'adore Fran c'est smcdorman
dans elle
voit comment n's oui oui oui le truc ça
c'est le film k César bouie d'uner
laisse-moi attends je vais le trouver je
vais le trouver dis-moi juste le début
la nuit la nuit du 12 pard le plan est
pas le plus facile parce non mais non je
connais ça c'est les chocolats non je
trou for gum non mais ça va pas du tout
tu vois non mais c'est la Press qui joue
aussi qu'est-ce que c'est est-ce que tu
l'as il a un peu plus mais je pense mais
recnais rien attends je reconnais un peu
ah si je l'adore ce film bien sûr 12 mat